We will see what they say. Uh, this
thing is not built
for built the way it needs to be built
for this yet, though. It should be
pretty easy to adjust. But holy hell,
that is the first time I've gotten an M
to OM a machine. You have to try pretty
hard to do that.
minor benefit of WSL instead of your
machine.
Well, there config setting to load less
data.
Yeah, let me finish. Let me at least get
their have something train with
ass. What game is
that? Oh, wait. I'm trying to remember
what game uses that note like that uh
that
term. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's League and
Dota. Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, RS only has
um you got prayer points, I
guess, but they're not used to cash yet.
They're used for like they're used to
fuel
passives. Machines out of
mana. It's more fun than out of memory.
I mean, I could
technically it's going to be so stupid
slow if I do like 64 m or some dumb
[ __ ] Can I do like
something somewhat
If you start using too much memory,
you're getting killed.
I mean, this doesn't scale as badly as I
would
expect. Did I like run out of file
pointers or something?
Okay, this is the last one we'll try.
We'll do this and then we'll see if I
can get above 70K. 70K is not good
enough.
Yeah, I don't know what what happened. I
think that one actually did OM,
but let me get this thing to run for.
Actually, let's put this
Neptune and then I can look at PR as
this is going to take a while. Or not PR
results, I guess.
How is there yet another freaking
Discord
update? They've just been like shipping
nothings.
there's Oh, Neptune's
missing.
Annoying.
Go. Okay. You linked me this
2. What do you mean? It looked good and
then collapsed. Oh, this.
Yeah.
His GPU drive isn't merged right
Spencer. I don't have it in my main
puffer branch to play with. Right.
Can you get a version that
doesn't Can you get a version that
doesn't use masking
uh and do like just a whatever PR to dev
so that I can play with it and help
you because like we've got the new stuff
is kind of dissolving everything at this
point. So like if I can just throw my
new stuff at it, it probably will work.
Okay, finally this does something. Is
Ryan still
here? I can look at that
Send it. Happy to hop on. Sure
thing. This can finish running in the
Hey, can you hear me? How's it going?
Pretty good. Let me send this stuff
over. I didn't realize that I wasn't
using this. Like, I just max this.
Max what? Max audio quality in this.
Oh, I don't think Oh, I have no idea how
that works, Captain. I just I haven't
done them yet. They should not be
disabled. I just I haven't added them
yet. I'm pretty sure our current J
treats truncation the same as terminals.
We just never bothered with them yet.
All right, let's Also, hold on. Before
we do PPG, you have to look at my
message in general.
No, before this you got to look at my
message in general. CRT.
Yeah, they're fun.
They make they make uh pixelated stuff
look nice.
I see. I wasn't sure if I was like
wanting to go like the like kind of
pixel crunchy scan line route or the
um like like the high high fidelity like
do did you ever see like the old
like like these style of games where
it's like they added a bunch of lighting
effects and
stuff and these were not pixel crunch.
They were like smooth shaded.
I might have seen these. I mean there
are like better ones. Like basically
they're just
like I don't know. I to be honest I have
no idea what'll look good. We'll see. I
actually the guy on X. We'll see if he
replies.
Nice. The uh the scan lines are very in
fashion now for some reason. I've seen
them in like four new indie games. I
don't know why, but they look nice. I
really like them. I don't know. They
definitely make the pixelated graphics
look better. They just pixel graphics.
Yes. But not so I did like the moa. So
this shader, right? Um this is Where is
it? So this one is
Where is it?
Yeah, like this sort of like fade stuff.
I think it like there's no bloom shader
on it or anything though. Oh yeah,
that's nice. Glowing, but it could. I
don't Yeah, I was figuring maybe if we
get shader magic guy, maybe I could pay
him a bit to like make us some cool
stuff.
That'd be cool. Yeah. All right, back to
research. Hang on. I've I've been told
you're too loud. One second. My bad.
I'll just mic you way the hell down. All
right. Research.
Research. Now you're super quiet there.
I can start screaming. You're
good. Well, I'm gonna actually have to
do so much AV setup um probably tomorrow
or Friday. Uh I don't know. So, I
ordered 16 different things off of
Amazon for a professional grade AV
setup. Well done. You're moving up.
Yeah, it was fulltime streamer. Hey, I
figured it's cool, right? It's like all
the dev gets done live. So, honestly,
it's fun.
Yeah. So, the ppg stuff is definitely
um interesting.
Mhm. I don't know how else to put it.
The uh
you DM'd me or take this again. Where
did you put this? Uh I just sent it in a
DM. private research results. Let's
say ppg.
So obviously when you don't detach the
critic network, the baseline's a lot
better. So that's the red versus blue.
So when you don't detach the critic
network,
so is this just PO?
Um it's similar. It's almost PO. You
could think of it as PO. Um
if you uh the issue is that PPG has like
a couple minor implementation details.
They do like advantage normalization um
over the full batch rather than the mini
batch and like one other thing, but it's
more or less PO.
We actually probably should do that. But
yeah.
Um but yeah, if you
um detach the network, I mean it
performs the same as if you don't.
um when you use the auxiliary updates.
So, it kind of seems like you could be
doing what you were suggesting where you
um you don't detach anything and you
just use the auxiliary updates like add
sample efficiency.
Obviously, that isn't exact nice.
Yeah. So, that's I mean that's step one.
There is still the um it's like a decent
perf gain if you look at it like the
sample of of this
Yeah. Okay. That's nice. That's nice.
You saw the latest like did you see like
the latest stuff we did with um we now
have one config that works on everything
that's running at like 4 million steps a
second on some of the amps.
Sick.
So the new algorithm stuff apparently
has made hypers more robust. So now the
question is like with this type of a
thing can I add an extra like let's say
that you just you basically keep the
same result on the same PF when you have
EO set to zero.
Yeah it should be right or is there more
stuff?
So there's a little bit more. So I mean
if it's set to zero then it's basically
PO. You could think of it that way. Same
wall clockish right? Like sameish
result.
Uh yes. I'm trying to think if there's
anything I'm missing. Yeah, the there's
no there's no other big computational
step. So, wall clock should be the same
with the way that I suggested, right,
where you you detach or you don't was it
you you do the value and the uh the
policy in the same update without
separate networks.
Yeah. So, that would be if you don't
detach them and you're just updating the
full network. That's how like PPA
normally works. Yeah. So then basically
the thing the goal here is like you keep
your base algorithm identical but let's
say literally all I do is I change the
search criterion in protein from wall
clock to samples
and now we have sample efficient puffer.
Yeah. So there there's some caveats
here. Um but that in con like in theory
yeah that makes sense. Um the caveats
are that if you there's more to PPG than
just attaching the uh the value network.
There's also the auxiliary head that you
have to add and they still like they do
the KL loss and everything. So you still
have to modify the architecture to make
this work.
Just need to add the extra critic head.
I mean this is like a solid
enough result. Why couldn't I get this
thing to do anything for us is what I'm
wondering.
Uh I don't know with it. I could have
just been lazy with it.
That, you know, it could be anything,
right? It could be like one like tiny
implementation detail that's different.
It could be that it just doesn't work
outside of procgen. That's always a
possibility. How hard is it to test it
on like
um you could test the clean RL code on a
puffer back end? It's the same
interface, right?
Uh probably I think so. I don't think it
should be hard to swap out. Grid is a
really good end. Like grid and tower
climb are both really good ends because
they actually take a little while to
like learn stuff. So the results should
be meaningful.
Okay, Spencer, I could take a look at
it. Do you want me to
remove the
skip? Remove the skip at specific
agents. Yeah. So Spencer, they're going
to have to like stay at the goal. That's
part of what they're going to have to
learn, I guess.
just a hack for now until I figure out
the masking stuff's actually kind of
obnoxious to get right. So, we might
have to change the end longer term.
Whatever. Um, yeah, this is a good
result. Like this is all Thanks, Ryan.
Um,
there is more to this though. The
um so I'm sure to explain this. So, when
you do the auxiliary update, you have
the auxiliary network. Um, so you can't
just like add this on top of PO because
it's an architecture change, right? Um,
you could maybe like if you have control
over the architecture, maybe you could
modify that and figure it out. But this
is not academia. We have control over
everything. Well, I mean like maybe if
your user wants to make like a custom
architecture, then it's kind of
a it might be weird to add an auxiliary
network on top of that. Just has to have
whatever heads we want it to have.
That's fine.
Okay. I did also try running it, it's
not finished, so I couldn't get the nice
plots, but um I tried running it without
the joint lo like any of the um KL loss
or auxiliary loss. So I just set them to
zero. So it's just doing additional
value updates in the auxiliary phase.
Wait, what? And you get this kind of
weird curve where it's very unstable.
Oh, you just sent it. Sorry. Oh, sorry.
Sorry. I sent another picture. Explain
what this is again.
So in the previous figure that you were
looking at it was doing the full
auxiliary phase. So it was updating the
value network, it was updating the
auxiliary value network and it was doing
the KL loss between them. This means
that you shouldn't do the auxiliary
update very often though, right? It's
every 25 iterations. Yeah. And that's
how you're doing it here.
Yes. Yeah. Exactly the same as the
original. Um the now pink and blue lines
that you see here are if you remove the
K loss and the auxiliary loss. So
effectively if you didn't have the
auxiliary head what would it look like?
And it doesn't matter. Oh no it doesn't
it's weird. It's it still outperforms PO
but it's way more unstable and it
performs worse than regular PPG. H.
So this is you need the behavioral
cloning loss is what this ablation is
doing
kind of. But it's interesting that the
value training still helps. So the next
thing I'm going to try is doing the
separate like just increasing value
epoch and seeing if that just does
better eventually. Right. If you like if
you just if you get too far away from
the policy network, you'll break it
eventually.
Uh probably I don't I guess I don't
actually understand why it drops like
this and then increase but it I don't
get why it collapses but still performs
better overall.
I don't know. Cool curve though. It's
weird. I would try I'd start trying some
of the puffer m because like even with
the cleaner defaults if you just up
number of m and use our stuff like it
should still be a heck of a lot faster
to run experiments than it is on this.
Yeah. I could try that. Have you seen
the latest params?
They're kind of changed.
Okay, so this is the param set that
works on like literally everything. Uh,
so gamma gamma lambda for this one is I
didn't try uplating these, but usually
gamma
95 lambda whatever. The key is learning
rate
05, mini batch
32k, and 8192m.
Oh, that's for bigger networks. Here's
the It gets even more deranged for
smaller
networks. So for all like the small
network experiments, this is the set
that works. Learning rate
05V minus
2 and mini batch 32K. This actually
trains stably
is a very large learning rate. Yes. And
this like perfectly matches for most of
the M's the learning uh the curve of our
previous version stuff. Like for several
of the M's it's exactly the same. For
some of them it's a little less sample
efficient. Mhm. But then like this
breakout here trains at like three
points off the million steps a second.
This 29 seconds or whatever for 80
million steps or less. That is kind of
crazy. Yeah. So puffer very fast.
And the cool thing about having this one
hyperparam set on all these ms is like,
okay, so here's this trade sim client
end or whatever. I just throw the
defaults on it and if it doesn't work,
it's because the end is
wrong. It's like pretty damn high
confidence.
I don't know if I agree with that
because what if the environment is just
harder and it like having large loading
rates harder on the harder M. The only
thing you have to do is uh reduce the
learning rate by roughly a factor of two
for every doubling of the network size
and it still
works. It's pretty cool.
And you're saying this works? What what
environments are you testing this on?
Like test this on everything? Everything
except I think there are like a couple
M's that have like legacy gamma lama
gamma lambdas and stuff I haven't
ablated fully, but yeah, I've thrown
this on pretty much everything so far.
And it's working on everything. Yeah,
we're solving RL.
Very nice.
It's pretty darn cool.
It is like it really does feel like a
different field. I literally though,
it's like this actually feels like a
different field. This is not the same
field I was working in four months ago.
I believe it.
Hang on. Found another student
interested in working on RL models. This
one wants to do drones.
We might have something in that space
coming up. We might be looking at
that. Yo, Ryan, do you have any idea
where I can get a a foam core or like
foam injection mold or silicon mold? I
was thinking what if we made
drones, but the shell is the outer shell
is a puffer. So, we have schooling of
puffers.
I think you need to seek help.
Hey, I know that that flocking paper was
so much fun. You want to come work on
that? I didn't touch that for like even
back as a dumb first year student, I
knew that project was cursed. We're
actually going to do something very
similar, but without doing like the
ridiculous physics that you guys did.
We're actually looking at that. I worked
on a lot of cursed projects. That one
was too cursed for me. Huh. We're going
to take a
crack. Uh I mean, I bet you could. I
think the hardest part was making uh it
was a C++ simulator for bird flocking
which you know pain.
We're pretty good at making the level
simulators now.
I'm just saying. Yeah, I mean you guys
can do that. So yeah, it might not be as
painful for you. Might not. Yo, Tyler.
Yeah, awesome. Like just uh D send like
send contact or whatever. I uh I next
few days I'm going to be setting up the
new facility, but I should be back quite
soon. I uh I cannot wait for new
facility. The only thing that is
uncertain is whether the flooring is
going in tomorrow or whether it's going
to get delayed.
It's like the foam mat flooring or like
actual flooring. Uh it is 3/4 inch
rubber.
Nice. Latest Dev Spencer.
Yes. I uh I found a used commercial gym
equipment vendor where I can get like
really nice high-end stuff at a third to
half the price. So uh I might have
bought a bunch of stuff.
Nice.
I might have bought a bunch of stuff.
I'm looking forward to it.
Um yeah, there's there's cool stuff
happening in RL for sure.
I like honestly with the latest results
in Puffer I like we can take on a lot
more like industry grade problems I
think that the like the tuning knob the
knob tuning of like sample efficient
versus timer like wall clock or whatever
is going to matter a lot. Um
pretty much like this is solving
everything out of the box
lately which is kind of nuts. It even
worked on Narmo. I have to recheck gamma
and lambda and stuff on neural mo
because I haven't checked it since we
did all the new stuff. Gotcha. If it
does, that would be absurd. Neuralarmmo
is not an easy end at all. Yeah, that's
the only thing I would be like thinking
about is All right, we'll look we'll
check it. We'll definitely check it.
That's the biggest model, too. That's
like 3 point something mil and uh it
trains like 5600k steps per second.
Nice. Which is actually low because we
have one that's 2.1 mil that trains at
1.5 mil steps a second. So I think we
could technically get neural MMO 3 over
a
mill which would be awesome.
So, if you wanted me to pick an
environment to try running with this
clean RL setup, it'll be the same code
for all of them to be fair. Like, it's
actually really easy once you have any
of them, but I would probably say do
like grid in latest dev.
Okay. Um, because it's it's a maze env.
It's like a highly configurable maze
env. And because you have small maze and
and large mazes mazes, it like
consistently produces very clean log
linear train curves.
Okay. Is there a like is there a
specific config you want me to use or
does it like automatically scale up?
Okay. So if you like this like this is
latest grid config. Mhm. Uh you can do
you can probably just do either 4096 or
lower whatever m whatever makes sense
for clean RL. We use really big mini
batches. Honestly clean RL will probably
be decently fast with this many ms. Like
it's not going to be near our perf but
it should be decent. The only thing I'm
not sure is our hyper prams. Like stuff
might not be easy to get good results
because clean arrow is missing a lot of
our new stuff, right? Muon's awesome.
Sign and alien's awesome. The new puffer
advantage filtering is great.
Are these hyperparameters for your new
stuff or are they for because I probably
want to get like regular PO
hyperparameters if you have those from
past experiments.
Um, like not with your new stuff because
I'll be plugging this into PPG.
I'm trying to think how you would even
get that is the thing, right?
Like you kind of just have to pick
something I guess that like trains
somewhat. Um, well, you were working on
these before you added all your new
stuff. Like don't you have hyperameters?
Like you could look at like 20 or
whatever like the hypers that we use by
default for stuff in there. Um, yeah, I
might do that for the grid environment
just because probably be way different
is the main thing. But like generally
stuff feels jank, right? It's like
with the older stuff like RL feels jank
and you have to do 200 experiments to
get params that work anywhere and now
it's like you just solve it.
Just solve it.
Yeah. I mean this the next update is
going to be all this these new
algorithms right all like the stable
configs good baselines really really
fast training and I'm hoping we get in
uh GPU drive impulse wars tower climb
and then best spot like blaster and
carpull as well and also CPR this is
common resource problem um so we get
like six new m three of which are quite
large
did you notice that you just did the
exact same thing that Danagar did but
for PP
PO. You wrote a bunch of implementation
tricks that actually make things robust.
Um,
but it actually works for PO.
Yeah, mine works. Um,
I I mean optimizer is like optimizer is
a big one. And then
it's new advantage function, I guess. I
mean, these things are more grounded
though. They didn't come out of anywhere
like just anywhere right hover advantage
filtering is strictly vrace plus J.
Mhm. And just like a CUDA implementation
of that. So like we actually recomputee
advantage for all samples to do
prioritized replay. Like we recmp
compute advantage for all samples every
mini batch but it's in CUDA so it's
fast which is kind of cool.
I haven't even tuned stuff recently at
all. Like I think that when I go retune
breakout and stuff, we're going to get a
sample efficiency win just out of like
retuning all the params with the latest
uh the latest stuff in
I you tell you this yet, but uh what
you're doing cool [ __ ] That's all I
have to say.
Well, I I think that um at some point
soon I'm going to just like
uh probably do nothing but well, I say
this, but this is kind of what I do
anyways. Do nothing but stream stuff for
a month. But the difference is going to
be I think I'm going to go super deep
into Aloland. And basically I want to
figure out everything that DeepMind
discovered over the last five years and
published and like what of those methods
actually are practical and are robust
versus which of them kind of don't work
generally. Yeah. Or like which of them
are just like unpractically
impractically slow. So I think I want to
like at some point just like do the full
algo pass on that and then at that point
you know our inference faster. If we
actually get core algorithms, then it's
just like,
okay, we can solve whatever at that
point.
Sounds like fun.
Yeah. Like I bet if we like if this
versus original Dota, this has got to
already cut down the like train time on
Dota by at least a few
fold, you would think.
So,
like we're getting to the point that
pretty soon we'll be able to
attempt like pretty hard
stuff. There are a few things left to
do. Well, then I think what the question
is, what do you want to do? What what
hard thing are you going to tackle?
Um, most likely will be a mix of us
making our own baselines and us looking
for people in industry with problems
that are commercially viable so that we
can fun this up. Did you know that
tariffs are really bad on the GPUs right
now? Everything's quoted plus 40%. I'm
waiting for this to hopefully come down
because I do not want my I think that
the current price for the GPU cluster I
want was like over
300k because of the tariffs.
So, I either have to wait hopefully not
waiting four years.
Yeah. Uh, we'll
see. I I'm going to get GPUs before then
for sure, but it just might be the case
of Yeah, we got to get a lot more
revenue to fund this stuff. We'll see.
Yeah.
I don't know. I'm curious. I I talked to
David today um about his startup stuff.
seems like they're doing they're doing
really cool stuff. Um, yeah, we're
helping them with a lot of it. Yeah. Why
can't you try to do what they did where
they just get like the funding to do
fundamental RL research? I I'm sure that
their pitch is different than yours, but
like I don't know. It sounds like they
got reliant on uh you're just relying on
a benefactor to bankroll you and then if
that gets pulled, you're kind of just
screwed.
I like this is actually like very viable
and profitable. I think it's very very
likely we'll be adding a third client at
the end of this week uh at the moment.
Okay. And likely one of the other the
existing contracts should go up. So like
it's actually starting to get to be
pretty reasonable.
Nice.
An uh physics based robotics like it's
hard. It's very hard. We could do it. I
think we could do it really well.
But it's not the type of thing where
we're just going to like do it to enter
that space, right? There would have to
be like a big client that wants us to
like do that type of
stuff.
Yeah. So, I don't know. It's uh it's
very exciting stuff though at the moment
like all coming together. I tried I
tried M0 as well on uh all day on
Saturday. I couldn't get it to do any
better than the baseline, but it feels
like there's potential there.
Yeah, Muse feels like
um feels like a real algorithm. Feels
like there's there's there's value in
it. It just uh yeah, depends on the
environment in a sense. If you think
about it, it's literally just it's use
search to collect better data. Yeah.
Right. Makes a lot of sense. You can
just combine it with PO and not really
change the training objectives all that
much. Yeah.
interesting. I think you probably want
to pick a uh probably want to test it on
a board game though
where the search will matter a lot. I
mean, we have go.
Yeah, if you could do that that I mean,
that works. I think the issue is just
that the search is like like I couldn't
get do anything anywhere but I only Were
you testing on board games? I tested on
a bunch of stuff including Go.
Okay.
I like I only spent a day on it. So
Gotcha. That just cuz like the main
algorithm ch algorithmic challenge of M0
is that like planning over Atari time
horizons.
You have to plan so far in the future to
get like a meaningful change because
each individual frame five steps or
whatever.
Did they use it in Atari? Yeah. M zero
they did. Oh, I forgot about that. Yeah.
I thought it was just a cheso. That was
alpha. Like this is the one that doesn't
need the state model, right? It uses
learn world model,
right? Right.
Experience from research would be best
form of experience. just expensive,
right? So, like again, we're looking for
knobs that we can turn and if you turn
the knob one way, you get really fast
wall clock training for when your Sim is
fast. And if you turn the knob the other
way, you get really sample efficient
stuff. Technically, the objective
doesn't even change, right? The
objective is still always wall clock
time. It's just that the sim gets
slower. Um, no. Yeah. So, I was going to
look into efficient zero next. I hadn't
heard of unit zero. Jun Zero.
I don't know what that is. I'm I'm
skeptical of all these
things. It's just like the the the
um constant optimizing on Atari games.
It's uh I don't know. Yeah, I feel like
I've seen enough stuff not generalized
that it makes me kind of sketched out.
Search itself is general, right?
Maybe. Maybe like the concept should be
but maybe the implementation. Yeah,
we'll see what Jang tricks they have. I
looked at
um what was it? There's a literally
called meme or whatever learning 2000 uh
200x faster Atari and they're just
they're doing ridiculous
things like they take two weeks or
whatever per Atari game.
Yeah. Yeah. And if I remember like a lot
of the Atari stuff like I think
efficient zero uses
um some like custom representation
learning for Atari. It they they do a
lot to get that extra efficiency. You
know they it's very much an Atari
algorithm.
That's not what we're So I'm sure
there's something there, but I think a
lot of the the benefits
are probably Atari specific. Yeah.
This is why I want everyone to start
researching hard environments because I
feel like nothing we're doing is I feel
like we're not even moving in any real
direction if we're just only looking at
the same environment for every paper.
Well, now we have all the ones in
popcorn and it's still growing. Yeah.
Now that is that is the way to do it.
Zero for continuous action didn't work.
Yeah, I haven't if I can get it for
discrete actions to work then I'm
confident I can figure something out
there. Until
I mean, Puffer just makes it really easy
to iterate on stuff from like you have a
thing that's like working to getting the
best possible version. It's just so fast
to
literally like do have to hop off now,
but uh I'm going to run that. I'm going
to try running PPG with just increasing
value at box and see what that looks
like. Um, and then I'll try running with
the grid environment at some point.
Sounds good. This is break at 3.2 3.3
million steps per second as well. Nice.
Like don't hold your breath. Actually,
you could because it would be done
training.
That's a nice tweet. Yeah.
I I've been saving that. We'll see.
All right. Well, let me know how that
stuff goes. Um I will hope I got to get
more boxes so I can swap compute. But
you have compute for now until they
figure things out. I'm very good. Yeah,
they I I think I'm supposed to have it
like they shouldn't figure it out for a
year. I literally just got my account
renewed. I should be good for a while.
All right, I'll see you around. See you,
Ryan.
Okay, we have PR from
Spencer 2K
lines. I wanted to learn about the prito
optimal thing you were doing the other
day right here, my
friend. So, it's in dev
branch. If you take a look at this file,
it's only there's 600 lines, but it's
really like 300 lines of actual stuff
related to this one algo.
It's called
protein and uh the core math is right
here. It estimates
uh the cost of any given hyperparameters
and the score of any given
hyperparameters and it attempts to fill
out the parto front of best co uh best
score for any given
cost. And uh it's built on well
Originally, this started off as a
modification to carbs from
inai and then I did a ton a ton of work
in testing. This is much simpler than
the original carbs, but uh it is robust
in a lot of ways that the original isn't
and it's a lot
Spencer Syon. We can
ignore 200 line C file. I mean, we've
reviewed this code already,
here. Oh, I guess you did the
pre-processing in the
Python.
Cool. Let's uh just yolo merge this
Oh, I also need to hang on. I need to
paste one thing before I do this. I need
to just paste the results of that train
run right
there. Or not this trade run. Where?
Where'd it go?
You need the config file and the drive
the what you mean the config
config? Oh well. Can you commit that
real quick? And then
uh yeah, if you just give me the command
for the maps.
Hopefully uh we can get something
reasonable running on this. Commit to
dev. Yeah. Yeah. Just commit the config
ocean GPU drive. Commit the Why wouldn't
you? Is it the any file, right? config
any and then the downloaded maps. I just
need the command to download
them. I'll just make
another Wait, why wouldn't you commit it
to Why wouldn't you commit the any to to
dev? It goes in ocean, right? It
shouldn't conflict with the original
because it's going to be puffer GPU
drive, right?
You are made for
any. Thank you.
And then just give me the data download
command.
Thank you,
Spencer. And where's that data folder
go? Oh, yeah. Yeah, we did this the
other day, right?
Um, is it not
data? It should be like resources or
something, shouldn't it? Or do we just
make a data dirt
right. Huh. It rate limited me so I can
no longer get my
token. Give it a minute. Hopefully they
uh they stop
that here. Let me let me run this in the
meantime.
Holy, what did I just get
linked? Update on sweep.
this. I imagine it's not. Oh, there it
is. I mean, you're doing something,
right?
80 and 250
mil. So this will be the uh the magic
number to beat.
What browser I made the hugging face
account
Chrome normally nukes if I have that
many line graphs.
on the new
desktop. You would hope it
And uh the command that you gave me
was this one.
it? Do we get
um Oh, I have to pull the
config, which I was pretty sure that I
had
presumably. Did you not commit the
environment
Uh yeah, you didn't commit the
environment or the model, Spencer.
uh the
environment and I mean mainly I need the
policy
uh PR was missing the environment file
like the end binding I added that that's
easy but I need your policy file or like
your I need your policy even just to
copy in. Can you link me your
latest your latest uh policy file so I
can just drop it
I might have had a slight ulterior
motive in
uh and then I also might want to mess
with the graphic colors on it.
file? Uh, it's not built like it's
there's no GPU drive in
here. It's just missing some
files. That's
faults. Uh, resources
Nothing in
here. You need app what? Run Python
Joseph,
there is a line in Maine.
Oh, I think my headphones are breaking
down.
Aaron is in Discord with you, by the
way. Well, I didn't have headsets on, so
what's up, Aaron? Uh, no worries. I just
took out my headset as well. Um, before
you head out, could you push a small
update into the multipprocessing code
just to give me a notify function? I
wasn't sure if your buffers mess [ __ ] up
on that. If what messes me all the
buffers when I was looking through the
multipprocessing code, it was not nearly
as um simple as it used to be.
Um yeah, that probably would confuse
you. Yeah, I should be able to add a
little not it. It just needs to like
call notify on all of them, right? Yep.
Okay, let me do that. Give me a second.
Let me at least make sure this end does
something. Then we will do
that. We're getting GPU drive integrated
right now live. Oh, cool. At least the
current version. The new one. Yeah, we
need to rename it because it's no longer
on the GPU.
Offer driving.
Look at that.
Look at this.
I'm trying. One sec. I just got up. Hey,
bet. What's up?
man. That's cool. You change the step,
you can see what they're supposed to do.
We'll do one
second and then I'm while this model
trains, I'm going to fix the back.
You want a notify function in
multiprocessing soon?
Yep.
Give it a sec, Spencer. Let me do one
thing real quick.
And I have to add this to cereal. I
presume most likely I already put it in
cereal, but if you put your that's fine,
too.
Okay, that that ought to work. Um I
guess I can test it real quick.
Uh, I'm on I'm walking into the lab. So,
hi Joe.
G's in Singapore. Oh, yeah.
Traveling for conferences. I hate
traveling.
Yeah. Last time you did it, we nearly we
nearly killed you. Yeah, you straight up
nearly freaking killed me, man. I've
been working my ass out trying to get
the fitness
back. Back up squatting 200 200 for like
easy sets of eight at least. Now I got a
knee that's going bading out. I had a
six-inute mile today. Joseph, what?
Six minute mile. You did a six-minute
mile. Pretty fast, huh? Are you kid How
the hell do you go from doing what you
were doing to doing a six-inute mile?
Just a little Just a little pep talk
from you, obviously. Are you Are you
freaking kidding me? I couldn't catch
the guy in front of me, though. I don't
know what his deal was. He was wearing a
a [ __ ] vest, like a wolf vest, but he
he was doing intervals. I couldn't catch
him. A six minutee mile's like really
freaking pretty damn good.
Yeah.
I don't think I' I don't think I've ever
run a six-minute mile, you know? I I
have kind of long legs. Uh that's rid
That's ridiculous. Like I think I could
do a seven at the moment if I really
pushed. Just a little inspiration,
Joseph. It's all it takes. And and some
additional effort, right? Yeah. My whole
interval workout is locked to 185
heartbreak.
Oh, well, my heart rate is probably
higher than 185. Uh I was about ready to
throw up. That's like pretty damn close
to max.
Yeah, I know. Jeez.
Uh, well, well done. Thank you. Thank
you. That's ridiculous. You should be
like, go like get a good 5K time then if
you're in that good shape already. Oh, I
can't run more than a mile that that
quickly.
If you can do a six, then you should be
able to do like a 21 minute 5K. No
problem. It's going to hurt though. I
don't want I don't want that much pain.
Joseph, what if I'm just happy with like
do 22 minutes out and it
uh eventually I'll run I run a fast 5K.
Don't worry. Where is What? What the
[ __ ] was I doing before bed is just like
suddenly gone to your athlete?
I'm not. No, remember the bench the
bench press thing? That was that was
that was real, too. You know,
bench bench plates 20 reps. No problem.
Got it. So, we are just mere mortals
compared to a bet here. I'm actually I'm
actually like nothing. I mean, Joseph
and Becky have been inspirational in my
in my quest for fitness to be honest
with you.
Six minute miles freaking hard though. I
My best I think was when I was in shape
for squash. I could do uh I could do a
14 minute two mile and I did a was a 710
pace uh 5k. I think those were my
best.
Uh yeah, I was testing your thing,
right?
So, uh, the notify doesn't do anything,
which is kind of sketchy because it
should break.
Doesn't do anything. Yeah, it should
break if it's correct.
What?
Hang
on. If Sam is
notified. Oh, I think that this can get
overridden maybe.
Let me grab my laptop and then tune into
your stream and see what you're looking
at
because I'm not seeing anything from my
phone. Okay.
stream. I mean, you kind of just have to
be able to read small text. I mean, it's
probably impossible on a on a screen.
Let me send this over to them so that I
can
So, GPU drive is fixed.
Uh Maybe.
Okay. On the laptop. Hey, Aaron. Uh I'm
just trying to think how I have this
notified because
like I think tech well I do this
your the thing that's a little annoying
is that like if you set the semaphore on
an M that hasn't returned yet it can
technically. Does that help Aaron or not
really?
I don't think so, but I'm not sure to be
honest. Here I can give you a notify
param on
send. So then all the M's that you send
stuff to get
notified. So like on sending
actions. So then how do we use that?
Because like the way it's set up now
didn't really do that super well. I
guess I can notify stuff. Yeah.
Um what what does notify do? Well, he
just needs a way to tell the ends to do
something. Oh, okay. Yep. I'm trying to
think how to do that. I can ver I mean I
technically I can add an extra buffer
for you.
bad. Yeah. I mean, how how how we've
done it with Pokemon is
having having the pipes
and morale. Yeah. It's slow as
hell. Actually, it's not that slow. It's
pretty slow.
It's a little messy
though. Adding you a whole ass buffer
for this.
Okay, we will see if this does
something.
expecting. So, I can send this over to
you, I
believe. Let me make sure I didn't break
anything.
Can you test this real quick if I sound
sober, Aaron?
Yeah. Okay.
Let me make sure I didn't break
anything. I'm just delivering all sorts
of results today.
I would just add it into the um dev
branch and then I'll just branch off
there.
Yeah. All right. There you go.
See if that
works. Always feels good pulling a new
dev. Look at Look at all those files.
Okay, it's going to take me a minute to
get there, but yeah, I'll uh let you
know once I've cuz I need to move all my
stuff up to that dev anyway. So, this is
going to take a
minute. No worries. I will
do GPU drive things in the meantime.
I kind of want to apply colors to this
thing. You can't control it in this
mode. I think you can do though. Um, if
the C demo works.
Is that the train? Is that a trained
model?
No.
Spencer, is this supposed to do
something when you uh Oh, it's probably
on pro test, right?
Yeah, looks like
it's I want the version that I can
control. Yeah, look at
this. Look at this freaking awesome
thing.
Holy. The lions are hideous as hell. We
probably need to do something with
that. Think I should uh should I theme
this real quick?
I kind of want to theme that real quick.
Well, you could make the Honestly,
making the road black wouldn't be bad.
Or puffer puffer black.
Yeah, that's totally what I had in mind.
I was going to totally use normal colors
like the same human being.
Well, now obviously you're going to use
the buffer colors, right? Yep. Let's see
how it looks. Adding those in the PRs.
here. I
see. Or I leave that for a second. Arrow
car. Hang on. I want to just do the
uh red. Honestly, I saw a lot of white.
Hang on. Road
edge. Yeah. Line color equals.
There's
black. Make that puff black. Yeah,
that's definitely Oh, yeah. That's
absolutely what I just did,
right? Let's see. We got to find the
road. Where's the
When do you make like unique branding
colors and you end up just making
fun. All right. What are all those
little black things we can't see?
It's not done yet.
And we're just waiting on as well. While
I'm doing this, Aaron, I'll uh pick the
notify
function and
hopefully that serves the required
purpose.
something. What's good? I'm just messing
with uh the colors of everything, of
course. What's good? I don't know.
That's too much.
still those are enemy
cars. It will show you only
the fuel. Oh, if you hold shift
Oh, I see. It shows you just the uh
Okay, that's really cool. Very nice. Why
Why does it keep crashing? Do we have an
actual train model? Why are these guys
outside of the grid, Spencer?
They're parked on the side of the road.
It seems like there cars here that
immediately Whimo data bad. I see.
Oh, this is this is with real data. Oh,
yeah.
Okay. What color do I make things so it
looks
cool already? It looks cool. It's a
little easier to see now. They aren't
inside of the road
edges. Probably belong to driveways. I
see.
Left and right for direction.
You going to drive, Joseph? This is how
you're going to learn to drive.
Shut up.
Bet. Okay, that's actually freaking
sweet. Now, uh, we need to get the cars
to be something else.
How do we get this thing to
like Where's the car
color? Draw
cars. It's probably this,
right? It's blue. The cube is like gray,
right?
vehicles? Oh, that's
good. Right. is if you
collide. Is this the active car or is
this the active car? The purple
one. What's this? This is a blue one
here and there's a purple one. What's
the difference?
Thought pink was like a stop. Purple is
human control. That's you, Joseph.
agents. Yeah. So, I mean, we're going to
have to change some colors.
What is this red
line? Something is wrong with that. It's
colors. Who's there? Hey, Plaza. Oh,
hey, Cap. Captain's in here, too. What's
up? What's up?
Is this collided? Hey, Captain. We're on
stream. What map you have on? What?
Whatever the default is,
right? Uh 227.
So, what are all the rays? I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know either. I'm just
adding pretty colors to things. I know
nothing about this.
I've been debing non-stop on like four
different projects today. So, I'm very
happily just at changing game
colors. Value ad has been established
for today. Now we get to have some fun.
Exactly.
Okay. This is pretty cool.
Um, quick question. Mhm. Um, so I'm I'm
working on the voids. Yep. And
uh I'm having this kind of uh vague
error message where the model expects a
specific tensor shape and I don't know
exactly what. Show me.
That's the point of being of having
everything live. It's really easy to
like get help.
Um I guess do you want me to share
screens or something? Whatever is
easiest. Stream it. Just you know, you
know, you're on stream before, you know,
whatever you're
here. Um basically I will, you know, I'm
starting to write this. I'm just trying
to get a single agent, like a single
puffer just going around the screen
randomly. Um and right now um uh
okay let's uh I guess yeah this is I'm
just you know trying to I started
messing around with the observation and
action spaces but um it looks
like this is what kind of controls the
input to the uh network right because it
basically takes in observations and
inputs and outputs actions, right? Mhm.
Kind of. Oh, yeah. Yes. That's all that
that work does. Those are the shapes.
Those tell you the shapes that you need.
Yes. Yes. So, I'm giving it the shapes
and I'm guessing this kind of propagates
somehow by telling it here. you kind of
uh in puffer n if you have some way you
you guys are propagating
um those observation spaces um like all
that does is all that does is tell us
the shape that things are expected to be
that's all that right um so technically
um so right now the problem I'm having
is my uh the model doesn't
uh like you know is not liking either
either whatever input size I give it
the model. Yeah.
The model. So you want me to put a break
point like like right here like in
inside the forward call. No in 16. It'll
be models models.py. The last thing
is at the bottom right there. This one.
Hi pim. You're we're live on stream by
the way.
Hello. Hello.
Right. I'm gonna Yes. What's the command
to restart Docker Aaron? It's
um just Docker PS will give you the
process and you can docker stop the
container and then docker sh
Yeah, sorry. I have music on. You're
good.
Hey, welcome.
This works.
[Music]
Whoa. Is this the default? Like, is this
the default color scheme cursor? I've
never changed it to the Doom Max one.
Okay.
I can learn how to use the debugger
actually. Cool. What? Um Oh, yeah. You
can do that as well. Whatever. Doesn't
matter how you do it. Yeah. I I don't
know. I'm used I'm used to like VS Code
style debugger usually.
Um I just need to know the sizes of the
tensors and stuff. So X Do you get a
console here or do you just get to do
that? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I can I can just
If I go to debug console, can we just
see the shapes? Yeah. Oh, I need to step
over them real. Yep. There we go. Those
are those are your your variables right
there. Huh. Okay. So, you have batch
size. Well, you can also just hover over
them. Whoa. Whoa. That's intense. Okay,
cool. Wait, hang on. Yeah. Yeah. That's
IDs have the things. You can technically
set that stuff up in even like Neoim or
whatever if you want. Yeah.
Yeah.
You would think I would do that, but
it's much harder.
Yeah, it's much harder to set up Neoim
debugging because you have to use like
a like basically there's like a
debugging interface that Neoim basically
plugs into.
I have a total of two plugins.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh you don't want to see my
confidence
I like. All right. Yeah. All right. I
kind of went and space N went N and
space N. Uh if
face shape
is just Does it say eight? What was
that?
Um okay, let's see. Yeah, eight.
Oh, you know what that probably is. Uh I
think this is probably on me for bad
documentation. Can you just go real
quick set the dtype of those spaces to
float 32 and see if it changes anything
or are you talking about in the uh in
here? Mhm. So like set the d type to
float 32. There's no type. Is that not
what it is? No, it should be float 32.
That's correct. Yes. Yeah, it's it's
like by default float 32 if I remember
correctly. Is is it float 32 here
though? I don't know if it's float 32 or
64. It's not float 32. Oh, but you were
saying in the models
Erin, you might need the latest
container for that. I can try to do that
in a second
or I can do it for you. Um,
well, it's the fact that it's eight
there is like what's the D type
actually. What's XD type?
Let's see.
Oh, it is 32. So, it's giving you back
eight. Oh, then in that case are you
like is your environment returning eight
numbers and not two?
Huh? That's a good question. Um, there's
no check on the native API. So like on
the emulated API, we actually check that
for you, but the native API is kind of
pro mode. So um, we don't check that
stuff for you.
I mean, basically my observations
are they're just Well, right now I'm Oh,
actually, it wouldn't Yeah, the thing I
said doesn't even make sense, does it?
Because
Go back to Python a sec.
Uh to the voids.py. Yeah, right there.
Okay. Uh shape is two.
Yeah, I'm just making them because um
well actually this is then
incorrectly the observation space the
what I'm kind of trying to create
basically here for now just to get like
to just get it running is it sees
um all the basically um vectors or all
the voids just basically all the um
every board that is in kind of the
screen. So, well, right now it's set to
return two numbers, but you're getting
eight numbers somehow, right? So, break
point at line like eight then
line eight on right here and voids up
right here.
That's there's eight. Oh, I'm it. The
line numbers are screwy. Uh, self. Yeah,
I'm sorry. This is relative line
numbers. I'm sorry. Self CMS is
cyborgs. My
my coding [ __ ] I don't even have line
numbers enabled. So, truth. Yeah, I I
use it just to like jump if I'm going to
jump up or down. Yeah, I guess jump.
Um, so what are we looking for now? I
just want to see after you after you
call super in it, I just want to see if
the ob uh the observation shape matches.
Okay. Now print selfobservation shape
said about nation space.
So the really cool thing about uh when
we actually get like contributed
projects uh and people are on the puffer
boxes is I just get to SSH them and help
them debug live.
Yeah. Joseph, what is stack smashing
detected?
Uh that security feature.
Okay. Can you explain why I just got
that on Vox 6 trying to run connect 4
default? Something's wrong with the
connect for probably possibly or
compile.
That's kind of weird. Just compiled and
went to run it.
What did you compile? Uh if you compile
with the address sanitizer, it might
give you more info when you try and run
it and that happens. Yeah. So I have to
fix it. Got it.
You shouldn't have to you can't mess
with the cement. Like there's nothing
that you should be able to be screwing
up in the sea, right?
You're uh no. Well, I was just
remembering that basically my
observations are just theian distance
between each of the voids and the one
that's currently like controlled or
whatever. Well, your observations the
way you define them, you will literally
only get one set of coordinates. Yeah.
Yeah. I just decided to define them by
equilidian distance basically. Can we
see voids?
Oh, we can.
So, where where was the shape? I didn't
see you. I'm dead. Uh the shape. Okay.
Yeah, I got shape right here.
So we have that
maybe then it should be so single
observation space is talking about
the like
what exactly does it define it defines
the observation of a single agent
right so let's say the observation of a
single agent is the number of
um voids Mhm. Mhm. And float just this
list of floats that is in the sh size
size of the number of voids in the
current environment. Then it would just
be num well you have some parameter that
defines the number of voids, right? So
it's like num voids. Yeah, I do. That's
all. Yeah. Well, the thing is like that
shouldn't be the issue. Can you do me a
favor and just make it not run with one
nth
in the uh by
you mean this? Yeah, like change that to
I don't know 30. Yeah, just change it to
something that's not one. I just want
because we've had issues with that in
the past and like nobody ever uses runs
with size one so we don't really get
good debugging on that. Uh I'm just
trying to start as simple so I thought
it would be the simplest way I
guess. I mean let's actually continue.
Yeah, but like I think that there's
probably a squeeze operation somewhere
in Puffer Code that I need to delete,
but I don't I haven't found it yet. One
second. I'm
gonna I'm gonna try running it.
Aaron, do you know how to build um
Dockers or No.
Uh like I've technically done it a
couple times, but not not really.
Well,
I the thing is to run the latest code on
that, you're going to need the uh you're
going to need the updated base
container, which I can show you how to
set up real quick. What box did I give
you? For now, for now, I just turned off
the CUDA compilation stuff and I'm using
the CVP instead.
That Yeah, okay, that'll work. That'll
work. And that'll tell me whether or not
it works. Yep, that'll work. I don't
know how slow it is, but it'll work.
Okay. Remind me I have to teach you
basic Docker at some point. Like that is
a very useful thing.
It's not too bad to learn either.
Play basics at least.
Plasma figure out your mouth.
You could just ask. What does this void
a void end exactly? or voids. This is a
really cool thing. It's It's a flocking
sim. Where's Ryan when you need him?
It's a really simple flocking.
This cool like this. So, that's just
roll base, but we're going to replace
the roll base with rewards. Yeah. And
I'm I'm basically making every single
one of those kind of voids um an agent.
Yeah. And the reward will be the role
based. So, so he asked for M to start
with and I said, "Hey, this would be a
cool project. Why don't you do this?"
Oh, yeah. Void is a bird object. Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. I was wondering what a void was.
Yeah. Okay. That's cool.
[Music]
Yeah. I mean, I hope it turns out cool.
And I'm I'm definitely going to use the
puffer um shape. Like I'm using the
puffer texture for the for each of the
boys. Awesome. We we very much like it
when you do that.
I thought it would be silly.
We try We like to use the puffer
wherever we can and we like to theme all
the Yeah, I I I saw that, dude. I was
running um Pong and the ball was puffer.
Holy. That's uh we got 12 people
watching stream now. Hey everyone,
welcome. We're doing some code reviews
on some RL stuff, trying to help debug
and intermittently messing with other
environments, kind of hopping back
between a few things.
Is this 12 across everywhere? Yeah. And
uh good time to mention this is all open
source work. Like this Discord is
public. You can kind of just join and
start writing stuff. Uh all the info is
on
puffer.ai and uh you don't really need
an RL background to get started. Most of
our best contributors came in with no RL
background. We try to make stuff easy
there. There you
go. Also, star of the star of the
GitHub. That really
helps. Oh, speaking of neural MMO,
Joseph, I was looking over at the
binding code and just the code in
general. I think I'm not I didn't look
very closely, but I think there might be
a bug in rendering with new bindings. Um
because it looks like you write to em
plural but then rendering is cm singular
and I didn't see anywhere else that that
was defined. I didn't test local
rendering with the new bindings so I
probably broke things. Yes.
Just letting you know. I'm not sure if
it's broken but it looked like it might
be. Yeah, we'll do. Thank you.
To fix for the next update.
Uh so there you go. So you have 3 by
two. That's the arcade.
That's the X shape. But then the space
shape is eight. Why is it eight? I got
to figure out. Okay. Can you print
something? Print end. Single observation
space or what is it? Uh print
cell. No. No. What you should do is you
should put the break point on like line
12 up there or whatever so that we can
get the we need to know what the single
like we need access to the end and we
don't save the end in the policy. Just
put a break point anywhere there.
Anywhere in in the in voids.py, you
mean? No, in in the Oh, in the models
like right where I'm looking where I was
looking at the code. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So, like around here, I guess.
Hit vault.
Okay. Lovely.
Um, does it have any other information,
Aaron?
Nothing else. We're in box five.
Okay, I will help debug sec Vault in a
second as I You know what? Debug two
things at the same time. Why not? No,
no, don't don't worry about I'll I'll
try figuring it out while uh you help
them with the cell phone.
This is how this is, by the way, this is
what makes it really easy for us to
collab on stuff. So this is one of the
other reasons we give people uh I mean
we give these to like like active
contributors who are doing stuff right
we have a limited number of these boxes
right now uh as soon as the tariff comes
down I'm buying 40 of these so
contributors will have lots of hardware
but right now I
don't I don't fancy spending 100k on
tariffs that sounds bad
no
seriously in meta deps puffer
Uh Erin, if you want, you can hop on box
six and and do your test because I have
the new container.
You guys can also run um Is this not
What is this?
What? What do I run? Just run it from
here or what do I do?
Uh into the meta folder into the deps.
Mhm.
Um, puffer
deep deep nested. I know. Move into
puffer and then just uh I did
what
is it called?
CD.
So yeah, CD into puffer and then uh
Python uh online LP demo.
And where's this? Do we know where this
faults?
Uh right after evaluate at least.
Um, I was checking on meta itself, not
uh, you know what? Let's Let's do
something.
hell? What are we looking at over here?
Me?
Yeah. Ob
shape. Oh, you're doing bumping stuff.
Okay.
Uh, I somehow I guess you didn't build
all the other ends, but it didn't matter
because you were just using
meta. I'm just going to check if your
thing segs on every end cuz then it
would just be whatever you did with
Auda.
Is that a Python version? That can't be
a Python version difference. I ran I've
seen that before. I don't remember why.
Are you on 312?
31. Yeah, I used to slice the key for a
dictionary and I can't do that, I guess.
I wasn't in 311, but 312 or something
ridiculous. They're they're they're
actually breaking things between 311 and
312. So there always are. Python, man.
They love to break crap.
Python's kind of just
so I use
I could have sworn that I had
Python versioning like backwards
compatibility is exact opposite of Go
backwards compatibility.
Go will like bend over backwards not to
like ever break anything. Whereas
Python's like, "Oh no, we only like we
only broke like five things. Come on, we
got to rack that up 20 at least for this
version." Ah,
I can tell you backwards compatibility
can hold a project or make it worse.
Look at C++. No, I'm not I I'm agree.
I'm just saying, yeah, like Go takes it
pretty seriously and I got Go is not
perfect or anything, but I think they do
a pretty good job with backwards compat,
but yeah, like C++ Yeah, it kind of
holds it back,
but for kind of for what they're going
for, I think it Well, no, there's so
much random crap. Yeah. Yeah, you're
right. Yeah.
Yeah, there's trade-offs.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, you got to It's very
hard to find the balance. Okay. So, I
fixed that other thing and you broke
everything with whatever you did with
the CUDA. Yeah, I just straight away.
Cool.
Um I Yeah. So, it's You can either try
it on box six real quick. B. Do you know
how to build the box stuff or No. Did I
do that? I do, but I have I have the new
box built like Okay. So, let's try it on
that real quick, but then Aaron um just
just log into box six. It'll log you
right into into my box. I want to show
them real quick. So all you have to do
for this is you just have to like go
into this. There's a dev branch of
puffer that has the new config files and
you just like change the image and the
name to like
base sh build-d based offer file and
then you build the next layer which is
puffer deps and then you build puffer
tanks. You just have to build all three
of them but you can use you have to run
you have to run it three times right
Joseph? I'm not crazy. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
There's probably a way to do it so that
it cascades. I just I haven't bothered.
Okay. I have I do three commands each
time I build a box. So, you probably can
make it cascade, but I haven't. All
right. It's I just just assumed I was
probably crazy. But, uh but you do it's
it's because it's three separate stages.
You build three separate. Yes, it is.
Yeah. No, it makes sense, but you know,
who knows if there was a way that I just
didn't realize it wasn't was a way. No,
there there is totally a way to do
multi. I just haven't bothered. Okay.
All right. Um, what do we have? I'll log
into six. Test over there. Yep. Got to
do that.
Uh, what are we looking at here?
Who? You. Me? Yeah. Do we have obsp
space stuff from uh So, the weird thing
is that is that it apparently doesn't go
into the init. It doesn't it ended up
the LSTM rapper.
Yes. Which is absurd because well it uh
what
does the break point but not does the
file
that's I can I don't know we can back
get a back trace or something
like that should be getting called. I
know. Yeah, that's exactly why. Oh, you
know why that
what what's your config file for this?
I that's the thing. I don't really have
a config file. Like I never
config file. You have a wild. There's no
config file for like the environment. It
should stop you. No, this this is
literally just the this is my whole
script of just trying. Oh, okay. You're
trying to You did something totally
different. Um I don't know. I just
looked at the demo.py and that's kind of
what I arrived at. What branch is this?
Is this 20? Uh yeah, this is forked off
20. Okay. Yeah, forked or branched off
to Okay.
Yeah. Um I
can like if I go
I mean there's probably some screwy
thing in there. Like can you not just
make
a if you just make a config and run it
through I guess you didn't want to like
put
yeah this is
u and I'm just I just worked it from
u which is this.
Yeah that's that's stable. Um I just
like you you're using it in a way that's
like
Yeah, I know. I I I just looked at so
what I did to get this is I looked at
demo.py Pi and I step through it and I
saw like when I do demo like when I set
the mode to like eval what does it do
and I just kind of created this like
small script I can use to test
RNN
class is
ocean and then make policy is not is
that used anywhere?
Uh I think so. Yeah. policy equal policy
class which is not make. So you're not
Oh, agent creators make policy.
Yeah. Okay. Go put a breakpoint in on
line 22.
Oh, you mean
that's which is now eight suddenly.
Yeah. Yeah. It's it's it's it makes
sense. Let's show that.
Better call that. And yeah, this should
be the image,
right? Like, oh, what? It skips it.
Uh, for future reference, I have linked
uh is it trying are you trying to load a
policy or something?
Like cuz it's not making a policy.
Yeah. Hit a
what? I don't I just Well,
this problem is not to get a back just
BT.
Back trace of what of just the uh so add
a break point if you just type BT you'll
get a back trace which is this you get
the stack trace of what code got called.
Um if I go
hit that break point and then in your
debug console you just type BT
uh like here
BT
now is your debug console is it not PDB?
Uh it is well I guess well maybe this
debug
I don't know maybe this like this is
like VS codes and I think it's based but
I love pi is it can you like is that not
attached to the break point is that
terminal it like what this is why this
is why I never bothered with the VS code
debugger because I didn't want to figure
it out. Yeah, this is I think the call
stack though. Okay, there's your call
stack then. Fine. So this calls demo and
then roll out and then
25.
So go to the was it roll out in 575.
So you do hit that, right? Mhm. So wait
skipping over it then. Right.
I I think so. Yeah. I don't think it
skipped then. Let's see. Let's let's
let's just try
this. Okay. Well, yeah, looks like it
is. And then print out the agent
creator.
Uh, yeah. All right.
Okay. Make
policy. Well, that's just going to give
you garbage. And then does it get into
your function that you defined in
demo.py
or third whatever my demo? Yeah. Does it
get there? Like
does it get like actually here? Well,
let's see.
Okay. Print out class.
Oh yeah, I can print out the
uh you mean policy. No, RNN RNN CLS. I
want to see if it's none.
Oh
yeah, should be it just got initial.
Okay, so
uh what do I get? I just I give it
nothing. Why is it
Eric, are you on box six yet?
Next line.
Yeah, hitting other weird things, but
I'm working through it. All
right. So, this should be tech.
Well, does roll out? Well, shouldn't it
just pass the arguments for betam or
does it Well, I guess but it should pass
on it should then hit the RNN class of
It should hit line 21, right?
This line. Yeah. Next. If it's not none,
it should go here. Yeah. Okay. So, now
step into that.
Okay. Yeah. Supposed to be hitting.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Then why why is it skipping
this deep one? Should not be. So next
line now print out print n single
observation space.
Okay. Okay. This is what I passed to it
shape.
Okay. So it's correct. So yeah. Why is
it here eight
then? Right? Because if I I'm just going
to continue here. Yeah. When I reach
here, if we look at
self was
two. Oh no, it is two.
Whoa. It was Yeah, I space
shape two. Then it should work now,
right? Let's see. Well, actually, it's a
Well, let's see. Is it just
running? I'm just going
to I'm just running
[Music]
it. Does it just
run? I guess. Yeah. Okay. I think you
got yourself confused with the debugger
somehow.
Yeah, probably. Well, it's working. Go
figure. Cool.
I suggest
PDB debug consoles.
So, plasma I linked I linked a uh a
little help thread that I that I have
going here in the this uh voice
for yeah for future reference. Uh, oh,
this will be there are detailed
instructions on on what to put where.
Uh, it's actually very simple, but it,
you know, it's not necessarily obvious
at the outset, which is why you probably
made your own custom custom file
uhation. So, it it's actually all there
and you really have to do not much to
add stuff. Yeah, before 25 releases, I
think we should um have some basic docs
on how to write an environment like once
we stabilize the new binding stuff. I
think that'd be helpful.
Um, quick question for you, Joseph. So,
I am uh working on the bindings and
uh so
basically right now uh I have a bunch of
constants and things I calculate that
just uh I use when calculating or doing
policy stuff in Python that come from C.
And with Syon, it makes it easy because
I just created a function that returned
a puffer love namespace, you know,
because Syon can access the CN Python
code really easily. But with the new
bindings, I can't do that. So, what I'm
thinking of doing is
them in Python and pass them to C or
they like Yeah, that's something I'm
think What What's that? That would be
the easiest thing for now. If there's a
way to like expose stuff, I mean, I can
technically do that as well. You could
also Can you not just add [ __ ] to the
Well, no, you can't just add [ __ ] to the
bindings.
Well, I was think so that's what I'm
thinking of doing. I'm thinking of
adding I'm not sure what to call it, but
basically um a function or a method
called like again I don't really care
what the name is, but something like m
info or something. What I'd rather do is
if here, let me show you what would have
to happen to make that really work very
nicely. Okay.
So see this end binding file this
methods thing this gets called an init
here. Okay so you should be able to add
arbitrary stuff to this but this gets
called here and you know by the time
that you've
done for
lib. So like let's say binding here for
this you'd have to like you could you
should be able to define arbitrary
methods here but then like the thing is
you've already included this up here.
So, I don't know if like you can add
additional stuff to the module after
you've initialized it or whatever, but
that would be like or if you can like
dynamically like add stuff, but that
would be the thing. If you could just
like have extra functions show up from
uh just like add arbitrary extra
functions instead of me having to make a
hook for every single one. That would
probably be the best thing.
It'll probably take you like very little
time though if you want to add them to
Python for now, just to get it running
first.
Yeah. Um, is there a reason in those
meth in the method table you have one at
the end that's just like nled
out this? Well, I don't know what this
is. This is some I have no idea what
this is
honestly. I I don't know if this is like
I like I don't know what this is. I saw
this in docs or something. I don't know
if this does anything. Oh, fair enough.
Exclude based on a define. I really
don't like like I really don't like
conditional compilation macros when I
can possibly avoid them. I had to do it
once for this and I hate it so much.
This is disgusting. Yeah, I saw I saw
you did that. I'm like, you probably
hated that. Yes, I did. I spent like
half an hour staring at it trying to
find a way not to do that. So, yo, what
is up with that? Like the shared my
shared stuff. What's that do? Shared
initialization. So, it gets called once
for all ends.
Okay. or it lets you do that. So we use
it for uh ocean
grid. So like the grid end of here has
this shared initialization that defines
all the maps and then you can load the
maps in. It's kind of cool. Oh, one
other quick question. Um did you have to
do anything special to get the uh
python.h um I don't know like installed
or something? You have to install like a
dev package for Python or something?
Maybe. Maybe it's Python dev. I don't
know.
Okay. I I don't know because I used the
Docker that has that.
Fair enough.
Uh Okay. What was I There was a thing I
was doing. Was it GPU drive? Was
it Spencer's not in here, but Spencer's
been sending stuff, so
So Spencer is on the stream. He's not in
the chat, but he's he is on the
stream above edge cases on GP drive. Is
this is this reasonable? Can I like add
this and then merge or did I break
something horrible
here? I mean, we can obviously iterate
on this and like we're obviously going
to have car models and stuff and also
the aliasing is horrible, but is this
chill like initial pallet?
You discovered a bug. Gotcha. I edited
the colors and discovered a bug. Cool.
So, we can iterate on
that. Oh, PR is already
open. Impressive, sir.
ah, you're saying
something? Uh, looks like I have no Oh,
I'm trying to um by the by uh with the
suggestion of uh I don't know how to
pronounce your name because it's super
long, but Bet. Yeah, just call. Yeah,
it's just call me B. It's cool. Okay.
So, uh by bet's recommendation, I'm
trying to instead of use my kind of
jumble together script to test my
environment by using just demo.py.
Yeah. Is At least that's kind of what
you're suggesting here. But I saw you
running an eval a pong was a pong eval.
Yeah. Um I'm trying to find where So are
are you making a Python environment or
are you making a C environment? Oh, it's
a C environment, right? But like it has
make a make a directory in in the ocean
directory with the name of your
environment. Yeah. I need to make an
indie file, right? Yep. And then in uh
chapter here.
Here you go, Spencer. It works.
Starts blue, turns red. Your active one
is red, which is probably a bad idea,
right? We should make the active one
like scion friendlier color like Yeah.
But then I don't know what to do with
that cuz like
Oh, by the way, there's a really easy
way to turn on anti-aliasing for RayB.
How? Please tell. Uh let me look in
is horrible in this. It is very aliased
because it's they only give you like
single pixel line segments.
Active should be purple or whatever you
Well, I need to figure out cuz I have
cyan for active, but then I need to
do. Can I change the outline on the
active
here? I just posted it in uh the voice
general. You basically just set config
config flags right before you do an init
window and you just say um msa4x hint.
Oh, interesting. Yeah. So on web it
doesn't do anything, but on desktop it
does. So I actually called uh I think I
used vector uh vector commands instead
of the uh the standard commands for I
just hopped things up. be easier than me
typing a bunch of messages on Twitch.
Hey, what's up Spencer? Awesome
environment. I am sir applying my unique
to say the least aesthetic taste to it.
Um stop developing sometime where I'm
from.
Fair enough. Um yeah, let's just clarify
what colors mean right now. So there's
the active agents, there are static
agents, and then there's your human
controllable agent.
And then there's also the color that
happens when you collide. So all of
those are four different colors. Let me
see what I So what I just did is I made
the active agent cyan. I just outlined
your one in green. Well, this will be
more obvious with the anti-aliasing or
whatever.
Um, and then it turns red if it
collides. And then the other ones that
are inactive are this like background
dark
cyan. Is that something? So did so does
each one get the green or just the
special one gets the just a special and
you can't see it now because the
aliasing and [ __ ] but okay okay this is
aliasing on a 1440p monitor
captain put this in the chat for us
right
I did
seven people in puffer voice this is
this is fun now all I need is 40 actual
boxes so I can give people tons of
compute to do cool RL
so you don't need the the second line.
Obviously, I just put it there to show
you where to put the flags.
Uh, you say obviously, but like I've
kind of been doing a lot of stuff today
and uh brain no work.
[Music]
Yeah. Are you kidding me? This library
is this good?
Dude, I love Rayson. Like, this is the
only good library. Like, all other
software is just bad.
Yeah, all other software is bad.
Well, aliasing's gone. I don't know.
Literally, all other software is bad.
This is good. So, what did that fix? The
lines sitting on top of each other.
Aliasing. It doesn't look horrible
anymore. Look how sweet it looks now.
Completely fixed. You probably can't
tell from low quality stream. If you
check like the main stream that's 1080p
or you run locally, like the lines are
no longer jagged. They're like perfect.
Ah, okay. It's beautiful on screen. This
is so nice. Holy. Yeah. which it looks
fine. Is it explosive vision? Yeah, it
looks good, man. Now, you can't really
tell with the green.
Yeah, it helps a ton in Impulse Wars,
too. It looks terrible without it. But
yeah, this one looks even worse with
without it with all the lines. This
really cleans it up. Now, I got to This
green outline's not cutting it, right?
Screen outline. What? So, we got to get
I don't want to outline in red because
that's like
bad puff white
anything that's visible really. The only
reason it's hard to see right now is
that's high contrast. Yeah, you have a
ton of lines obviously. Yeah, I mean you
can turn off the
uh the observation lines or just force
them to only be on if you like hold a
button down or something. I mean,
realistically, we're going to have car
models anyways.
Yeah, I just have all the lines flying
out because I wanted to make sure my
observations made sense.
all right. I want to see you drive
around, Joseph.
All right. So, go to step one thing.
What's the What's the thing for cube?
What's the arch for cube?
Think of it. Uh I don't know off the top
of my head.
Cube
is position with height. I probably
should after the tower climb stuff, but
position with
height length color.
like, oh, wait. This is the wrong ones.
These can be spheres.
Yeah, those are the um the goal points.
Yeah, but I wanted to try
something. But this is start and end.
Where's the other one?
Is this the You're right back. Where's
the like the points that are like on the
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. You saw it. Okay. So,
go down to the bottom or or just keep on
going through these versions. I'll tell
you when to stop. No, it it's the one
that's on I'll just say the line number.
How about that? Yeah.
Um it are you talking about the the
spheres that are the the grid in between
each road segment? Okay. Yeah, those are
um lines 1305 1307.
It should say draw a sphere, draw a
sphere, and then draw a line 3D above
those. Oh, this one. Oh, okay.
Yeah,
the draw line 3D is the road segments.
The draw spheres are
the center points.
I'm just trying to make it a little bit
It's probably faster as well because the
steers have to draw like all the slices.
Oh, okay. Also, if you zoom in, it's
like I don't know. I think it's cool.
You can't tell from up far, which is
also
fun. Why do these cars just all
instantly die?
Uh because right now they don't have a
policy. So you're just rendering this in
C, right? Mhm.
So it's set to acceleration uh index
zero and steering index zero because
they're they go steering goes from 0 to
13 and acceleration goes from zero to
seven spawn and disappear.
Oh, because those some of those are
showing up in the visible range of um
Oh, the car for like a split second.
Yeah. Okay. Um is this over this? What's
this perspective
right now? This is You're looking at a
global.
Yeah, but what's the camera perspective?
It's not like quite overhead, right? Oh,
no. I mean, it's just at some like
slight angle.
Have you tried the ISO?
I just picked random numbers in the make
client till it looked decent. Okay.
I kind of want to try like ISO drive
perspective and then like like behind
the wheel obviously, but then like the
ISO I don't know stuff could look cool.
Uh my guess as to why those are
disappearing is something I most
recently changed uh when talking with
the NYU
team. I think it's because some of those
are being marked as experts and then
they move like an inch and then they go
into like 10,000 land.
Yeah, I don't think this is a good idea
to be fair, but like what if buildings?
Yeah, I mean you could definitely just
spawn buildings in random places,
but I do you know how cool it's going to
look? It's going to look really
cool. We need bigger map though. This
map's small.
Yeah, I mean just pick a number between
zero and 200 and or 512. I don't know
which one you set up, but should be I
think 512 and then you'll find another
map. Some of the maps are bigger than
others. Some maps are small. Do you know
what's a big map?
Not off the top of my head. No, I mean I
can just pick random numbers till I find
one.
What was the map index in here? Where
does it say anything?
It's uh in the C file. Yeah, it's the
bin, but not under performance test
inside of demo. Oh, this is at the top.
Map name. You You saw
it, but in demo, not not performance
test. And then you just got to have it
be 00 something. You have to put a zero
in front of it's a three index number.
It's not going to
work here.
Yeah.
Okay. So, I think the this is a good
map. The perspective is not doing you
favors. I think
I think this is with the ISO thing
going, right?
This is like very slight
angle. Where's the camera?
It would probably be helpful to just
force everything to be in move expert
right now so you can see how cars run
around.
Okay. How do I do that? Go to step
Sorry, there's a there's a lag between
the stream and what's happening. So,
just give me a second till I'm I see.
We'll do this. Then,
wherever it says move dynamics, change
it to move expert in in
step. There should be one line next to
each
other. Yeah, just make that move expert
and then they'll all be on move expert
now.
Yeah, it's
cool, dude. You've built some really
cool [ __ ]
Yeah, this took a little while.
Not that long. It took you less time
than it took them.
I mean, yeah,
they have to do the first thinking. I
I'm just doing second round thinking.
Well, but you do fast thinking.
puffer. I'll make fast puffer. So
basically all the little lines are
raycasts I'm assuming like you're
visualizing the raycast that it's using
to see with.
I'm not using any raycasts. Those are
the raw observation points from the
relative coordinate system of what it's
looking at. And then I just drew a line
from the center of itself to the to the
thing it's seeing to make sure that the
coordinate was correct. Yeah. So that's
basically you're visualizing the
observations. It it's basically as far
as I can tell it's seeing with raycast.
It is seeing effectively with raycasts
but it doesn't like use raycasts.
Okay. Does that makes like I'm not
actually like shooting out a line. I'm
just visually shooting out a line. Yeah.
I in the rendering I get that but in the
engine itself it's not really using ray
cast.
No, it's just I'm just dropping in uh
points like saying like, okay, this car
is on this position. And then I do a
little bit of a relative coordinate math
to make sure that the angles work out
and then get it into its local
coordinate system.
So, how does that how does that work? If
if uh like there's two cars in front of
it like stacked behind each other or
something, can it see both of them?
Yeah, because what I do is I have every
it it
um it's going to search all of the car
list
currently cuz it is going right now I'm
kind of cheating. I mean in a way
it knows because you're providing it the
whole list of entities. All right,
there's like a huge list. Um it is then
iterating throughout the list of just
cars determining if its position is
within a certain range and if it's
within that range then it's in in that
observation. Oh okay. I see. So it's
basically just proximity vision. So even
if you did add walls or something if a
car was it would see it. Yeah. It would
Yeah. You could add like a brick wall in
front of it and it would still see it.
Okay. Gotcha. That makes sense. Is that
how it works in the original too? Mhm.
Okay. Interesting.
Yeah, they just use a within a certain
radius of vision you see things. Okay.
They technically have lidar as an
option, but I think for their results,
which they got really good results on
was uh using these observations.
Yeah, that makes sense.
There's only one key difference between
this and the NYU um observation set and
that
is okay. So the road like the map system
of how like road segments are are
seen is has different types. There's
like road edges, there's lanes, there's
lines and there's like driveways and all
sorts of other map objects.
Right now, I'm only including road edges
because in their system, they only
consider running into a road edge as a
collision and all the other things like
a lane is irrelevant, but they still
include the lane in their
observations. So, I felt like at the
moment it was not important to include
those because they're they have no role
in the actual action space.
Yeah, I would agree. It's just super
information the neural network's just
going to learn to discard pretty fast.
Yeah. I mean, eventually you include
that to do so you can stay in a lane,
right? So you can actually see the
lanes. But until they do that, it's it's
a very easy addition.
Yeah, that's cool.
And right now I'm just sweeping to try
and figure out a decent thing.
Uh, I can't figure out off the top of my
head here how this is supposed to
be above. Um, what are you trying to
accomplish?
Uh, trying to get like some sort of ISO
type perspective. And I you have to
actually do some math, I think, for
that. It's
And keep in mind that is stuff is kind
of annoying.
Um, okay. Well, we that's right now just
setting in order to find the map. It's
finding the first car and then pulling
away and zooming out.
then I've got to go. See you guys later.
See you. All right.
Cool. Uh, no seg fella on vets box.
Yeah. So you need
Wait, you said no fault. No seg fault.
Yay. So it works. Yep. And bet you've
been using a box. Yeah, you've been
using So that was the box that Aaron
that you had all the issues with. And
apparently this is the one you had
issues with. I fixed it. What can I say?
You're welcome. You did not fix it. I I
had to go disable secure boot which I
couldn't do that.
What? I got I got it fixed. Okay, you
got it fixed. I built the dev container,
too, for him. So, well, thank you.
All right, bet. Feel free to blow that
entire stuff away. All right, I'll just
leave it. Doesn't matter. Well, bet
that's not that's like you need your
containers to do your experiments. I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna leave I'm
going to leave everything. Okay. So,
next time you need you need you should
probably just swap boxes with it for a
bit if it's stable. So, that's fine.
Yeah, that's fine. We can swap
everything. Everything is pushed to dev
for me. Yeah, you guys can also just
like, you know, um do maybe like like
virtual machines or something. Two
people can be in one kind of uh No, we
don't we don't want people stepping on
each other's training runs. We do allow
people to have their own containers, but
the issue here is that uh it's a
three-stage build process for the new
dev container compared to just like a
one command pull for the whatever the
main one is. So yeah, and Aaron's
research side. So it's like I don't want
to make him mess with stuff. Yeah. The
main the main issue is that is that uh
we haven't tested any anything with
multiple runs going on on one machine.
So that just shouldn't be a thing like
it that
we very intentionally buy single GPU
boxes so we don't deal with that. Right.
Right. It runs, you know, specifically
in a certain way. All right. You can you
can have box six and I'll I'll get on
box five then.
Aaron box five. Is there anything I need
to know about it before I just make a
separate [ __ ] I'm gonna leave gonna
leave all your stuff. Okay. I'll make a
I'll make a new container, a new dev
container. Okay. And then that and then
that one will have the latest stuff
anyways. It's perfect. Yep. Um
camera was it behind target? Can I just
increase this?
If you want to increase that, it'll just
zoom out even further.
How do I get more of an angle?
Uh, it's the Y.
Okay. All right. Now that that's all
settled, I'm gonna uh take a minute and
go for a short walk and then go back to
work. Y. All right. See you later.
Later.
Uh Jason says
I'm pretty sure Jason is an LM
41 E66 doesn't have C render. There is
an error though art pull. That doesn't
make sense.
Yeah. Oh, the FOV is not what it should
be here. Interesting. Yeah. So you can't
do P
That's kind of
weird. Well, we'll leave it as a
perspective for now. I do think there's
some like cool iso play though with
That is a very suspicious use of the
dash.
Yeah, this this uh this zoom doesn't
even do anything. I quite like I think
it's because I'm overwriting it in C
file.
So, I need to like ratio this, I guess,
to like what's this like?
There we go. Okay, that's better.
Yeah, because the scroll wheel I think
it overrides the zoom. Okay, if I would
just Yeah, I'm going to push this as is
and then let me get rid of the expert
thing so I don't strip up your training.
Uh, well, yeah. I mean, so do you want
me to use that going? Well, I figured
you were doing your own training on this
because you took off masking and such.
Yeah, we're going to do a port.
Um, hang on cuz I have I have a sweeps
ongoing still from with masking and I'm
going to let that run for like two days
or something. I'm going to do one thing
for you right now on it as well.
The other thing I was going to do is I
think I'm going to fix the penalty
weights to the weights that they had um
on the negative.75 which was really
steep and then sweep off of that. Right
now I'm sweeping with the rewards but I
don't think it's going to matter because
it's always going to pick the least
reward to get the highest score in the
shortest time
period like the least penalty. Hang on
Uh 1,700. I think this is 1,700 as is.
Uh let me double check that.
There's a generally pretty easy way for
me to the current what I see is 1670 on
256.
It's it's changed a little bit because
I've made some things as to what agents
are and what agents are
not enough for two work for setup.
We're going to see.
Oh, is this the all the latest new
stuff? Can we Oh, okay. Maybe I'm wrong.
Um, match rows. Oh, okay. So,
you must match the existing.
There might be a This might be a me
thing. I think that this stuff has to be
cleanly divisible right now.
Um, let me pull on my MacBook and then
or let me pull it onto the puffer box. I
think I don't want to mess with my run
things for this
before. Yeah, I think I'm gonna have to
do a couple things to make training work
on this, Spencer.
I will. Yeah, because it's Yeah, the
whole like batch splitting is going to
be kind of weird. Yeah. So, I'm going to
leave this like this as is. Um, I'm
going
to if you want to play around with ISO
cam be fun, but I'll do it otherwise. No
worries. And then I will get this to
work Friday weekend. Depends how things
are going.
Um, maybe after dinner, even tonight. I
don't know. I have to pack as well for
my uh I have like doctor's appointment
in the morning and then I'm going
straight to a new
facility. Be traveling to that. have to
unpack stuff and then like all the new I
have to like figure out the whole AV. I
have to move furniture in potentially
provided the flooring is even done like
the whole ordeal.
Yeah. I mean I'm just going to be
letting the sweep run and then I'm just
going to be tossing in random runs to
two billion steps and to see if it one
of them works. You can do that on this
for now. this the new code for puffer
like the new dev stuff is really
freaking good I will say but I have to
like do some stuff to make it work with
this because there's like there's cuda
like thread need to be divisible by
power of two [ __ ] that I have to
figure out for you um but like literally
we now have all the like all of the
standard MS like the simple M's are
training at two to four million steps
per second and they like basically same
sample efficiency. Oh [ __ ] So maybe
this will get to a million now.
It's like we have like ludicrously good
RL stuff. I literally just like ran this
on both clients ends and just like
immediately beat their best. So yeah.
Okay. Well, I don't know. Yeah. Just
just hit me up whenever parameters and
like these are both projects where
they've been tuning stuff for the last
months. So like it's really freaking
good.
Okay. Then uh yeah, just just hit me up
on Discord when when you do your things.
I'll try to do it tonight. I'll see. Uh
and otherwise, I'm going to be I'm just
going to do my my tasks are still the
same. I mean, I'm just going to let it
sweep and find out what happens. Yep.
Let me just add the This looks freaking
sweet.
Yeah. The one thing I wanted to add in
that I thought would be fun for render
side if I would wanted to dick around
with that is uh the first person
perspective camera inside of the human
car. You have to do that.
I want to get a placeholder. Do you want
to just get like a placeholder low poly
car? Uh I can just find a model. Yeah.
And I can just dump it in there. Better
one. I'll just like I can the bigger MS
like this I'm very happy to commission
assets for. So, there's a bunch of free
assets that I found for like Tower Climb
online. So, amazing. It just depends if
you want. I mean, any of those work.
Like, all those things are free and
generally. Yeah. But like this isn't I
mean I I had a different thing in mind
than this, right?
Like this is like I mean, you can get a
pretty high def one. I mean, it doesn't
like I other way other way around, but I
want like I kind of want like like a
minimal like it's a car-shaped low poly
thing like very angular looking. I don't
know. I have an idea in my head. All
right. Well, maybe it's best for you to
execute that idea. Yeah. Yeah, of
course. But if you can get a placeholder
model loaded in then like Oh, okay.
Yeah. Yeah. That'll take me no time at
all. Just grab like some some decent
like this one or whatever. Fine. I can
do that. And then maybe I can even add
in like a road material. Mhm. Possibly.
We'll see. A m I don't know if we're
going to need a material. We do need
some way of knowing what is road road
shader would be cool
but then we would know need to know the
forward
direction I don't know we'll have to
think about stuff I don't know
maybe we'll see if this guy replies but
um let me find that guy I saw a really
cool guy on on
X see if he's he has not replied yet but
uh this guy is awesome
find them.
Oh, also one thing I thought was wild
that I was looking and I may be wrong,
but I didn't see anywhere in the in the
GPU drive architecture
um
a what's it called? An LSTM layer.
Yeah, they didn't have one because they
can't do it.
[Music]
That's why like they couldn't do it
because like their original train code
didn't have it. It was too slow.
H.
So, should we just keep ours and try and
find super parameters or and then deal
with it later or should I take it out to
see if I can We use LSTM for everything.
Okay. It's like the standard. It It's
actually more sample efficient too to
use the LSTM. The LSTM's been pretty
it's been good for everything. Honestly,
the reason people don't use LSTMs is
because they have their like their
implementations are bad. That's all.
So, it's slow. like the cleaner LLSTM.
It's It's hyper correct technically, but
it's so slow.
What do you mean just use Transformers?
Those are pain in the ass in the ass.
Those are actually hard to get right in
RL cuz the
uh collection
I'm just trolling cuz everything now is
like, oh, Transformers for
for for you know, sightseeing. I don't
know. Transformers for vision.
Transformers for fart detection. Yeah.
And then I tell people it's like, okay,
I was doing I was setting soda on
language modeling before transformers
existed. Go away. Leave me back to my
Leave me to my seat.
Okay. Uh, I got to go take a call, guys.
Um, I'm gonna go do that, grab dinner,
and then we'll see if I how quickly I
can pack if I come back later tonight to
like fix that thing for you, Spencer.
Um, but otherwise, since we do still
have a few people watching, hover.ai for
all the things, this is all open source.
You want to support us for free, start
the GitHub. If you want to get involved
in dev, join the Discord. Most of our
top contributors came in with zero RL
experience, so you can learn. And other
than that you can follow me on extra